[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche comté avec ce matin un nouvel
épisode du feuilleton sur les 80
kilomètres heure
sept mois après avoir imposé cette
nouvelle limitation de vitesse sur tout
le réseau secondaire est alors même que
le nombre de tués sur les routes
concernées par cette mesure a
singulièrement diminué l'an passé le
gouvernement semble prêt à faire des
concessions a redonné la main aux élus
locaux notamment alors le pouvoir recule
t-il face à l'impopularité d'une mesure
au mépris de la sécurité routière est ce
pragmatique est opportuniste on va en
débattre jusqu'à midi avec nos trois
invités
je vous les présente tout de suite
d'abord olivier guillemain vous êtes co
référent départemental avec philippe
antoine de la république en marche dans
le département du jura
vous êtes également élu municipal dans
la petite commune de lova tange
également sur ce plateau yves krattinger
président du conseil départemental de
haute saône vous êtes ancien sénateur
socialiste vous êtes aujourd'hui divers
gauche est à vos côtés cédric perrin
sénateurs les républicains du territoire
de belfort bonjour à tous les trois
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous en avez les bills l'habitude cette
émission c'est aussi à la vôtre vous
pouvez l'a commentée sur les réseaux
sociaux
interpeller nos invités nous faire part
de vos questions ou de vos réactions
grâce aux mots diez qui s'affiche dit me
paraissait comme dimanche en politique
franche comté je me ferai d'ailleurs le
relais de certaines de vos questions
tout au long du débat alors messieurs
après des mois de fermeté passées à
répéter que l'abaissement de la vitesse
sur le réseau secondaire à les faire
baisser le nombre de tués sur les routes
qu'il fallait sacrifier un peu de notre
liberté au volant pour notre sécurité
sur la route le gouvernement ouvre donc
la porte à des aménagements cédric
perrin la majorité de droite au sénat
plaide depuis plusieurs mois pour
davantage de souplesse
êtes vous satisfait satisfait oui mais
je dirais qu'il est grand temps d'ouvrir
enfin le débat nous avions à l'époque
largement contesté là là le dogmatisme
la brutalité aussi avec laquelle ces
mesures avaient été mises en oeuvre
puisque je rappelle qu'une mission
sénatoriale avait été désigné en avril
2018 dont michel raison et est le fer de
lance du sénateur de haute saône
également et il avait été que largement
demandé en tout cas aux gouvernants ne
prend le temps on ne mettra en place
cette mesure lors et de demander ou à
minima six mois est promu nice n'a
jamais accepté de prendre le moindre
temps il a décidé de prendre cette
mesure de manière très verticale et
dogmatique sans consulter qui que ce
soit et aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que finalement il existe des corps
intermédiaires dans ce pays
des élus des syndicats des associations
des gens qui sont des traits d'union
entre le gouvernement je pensais la
population et qui sont capables
peut-être aussi de réfléchir et parfois
de trouver des solutions donc
aujourd'hui on les écoute enfin je pense
que sur cette problématique des 80
km/heure et bien c'est le bon sens et le
pragmatisme qui vont peut-être
l'emporter encore que il semblerait
qu'entre le président de la république
et produits listés quelques divergences
sur la question et donc nous verrons que
lequel des deux gagnera il krattinger
vous aussi vous aviez émis des réserves
depuis un moment sur cette mesure
d'autant plus que la haute saône a
cueilli un tronçon expérimental pour les
80 km vous n'étiez pas convaincu dès le
départ moi je suis convaincu et je
l'étais de l'année dernière parce qu'au
mois de mars écrit au premier ministre
que nous devions construire un processus
entre l'état et les départements
départements qui ont en charge la
plupart des routes qui étaient concernés
c'est l'habitude de travail que nous
avions depuis les décennies trail avec
l'état moi j'ai proposé qu'on arrange
les routes en trois catégories
il en soit on peut encore rouler à 90
les endroits où ils être vraiment
souhaitable de rouler à 80 et puis ceux
où nous devons plutôt prescrire le 70
kilomètres à l'heure
parce qu'il ya les routes secondaires un
milieu rural dans les zones montagneuses
rouler à 80 serait extrêmement dangereux
elles sont pas déjà 70 ces routes a
coûté pour le moment nous sommes en
attente de ce que va décider l'état
moi j'ai deux considèrent cette mesure
comme eux en contradiction avec le code
de la route le conducteur doit adapter
sa vitesse aux circonstances mais aussi
au profil de la route est les routes
elles ont des caractéristiques
différentes selon le services qu'elles
apportent
il faut le prendre en compte elle cause
de la route il dit qu'il ya les vitesses
maximales aussi non il faut respecter
ces mots finir j'ai bientôt terminé
je dis aujourd'hui d'après les propos du
président de la république
la sagesse semble l'emporter on revient
vers ceux qui s'occupent des routes
toute l'année il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire sur le processus en question
on a voulu faire passer les élus locaux
pour des assassins de la route c'est pas
le cas
la route est un sujet dont nous nous
préoccupons tout le temps sérieusement
que ce soit d'autre à belfort dans le
jura et la haute saône et dans tous les
départements de france aujourd'hui une
tentation de revenir vers les qu'orateur
médias l'est de l'île aux causes que
vous avez très bien des chers collègues
ce soit
je l'espère mais s'est pas encore
exprimée de façon claire et définitive
olivier guillemain le débat est ouvert
néanmoins le premier ministre l'a
reconnu c'est quand même une sacrée
volte face c'est une volte-face bon il
ya déjà il faut prendre en compte le
fait qu'il ya eu comme un mouvement de
contestation fort et il ya une nécessité
d' écoute de ce mouvement nécessitait
des couteaux si des élus c'est à dire
fait aujourd'hui on recule devant les
gens nota il recule je sais pas si c'est
un recul c'est une une écoute tout au
moins de la volonté la population
l'expression de la population d'une
partie de la population il faut quand
même voir avant de taper sur edouard
philippe que la prise de cette mesure
qui est appliqué était de toute façon à
l'origine à populaire et il le savait
quand il l'a pris il a pris en
responsabilité en responsabilité par
rapport à des éléments très factuelle de
2 d'augmentation de la mortalité
routière sur les sur les dernières
années on a eu quand même des éléments
non je ne prends pas je crois pas il a
il a quand même été à lézignan olive et
grimages a quand même été à faire la
part des choses
on va laisser finir olivier guillemain
et je vous redonne la parole il était
comme aller coûte quand même 2 en
observation de ce qui est ce qui était
une augmentation nette de la mortalité
sur les dernières années il était l
écoute aussi laptop aussi s'il ya une
augmentation
après une année de référence en matière
de mortalité routière s'était 2013
l'année la plus faible est depuis 2013
on a constaté une légère augmentation
très légère mais certains le bon sens
passé et c'est redescendu l'angoissé
2013 est redescendu j'en passe et
peut-être aussi par d'autres facteurs
que le 80 km à ce que vous considérez
être réaliste on a une année est quand
même très sèche où les conditions de
route était sans doute bien meilleurs
que d'autres années est ce que vous
considérez olivier guillemain qu'il
s'agit d'une mesure de sécurité publique
bien sûr les études montrent ya aucun
doute pour vous là dessus il ya des
études sérieuses alors bien sûr
maintenant aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux on voit plein d'études plein de
la navy plein de choses comme ça qui
remettent en cause les études
extrêmement sérieuse qui conduisent à 7
ap à mettre en évidence quelque 80
kilomètres heure est une vraie mesure de
sécurité routière je me suis occupé de
ce dossier pendant dix ans à l'assemblée
des départements de france il ya trois
paramètres qui interviennent de façon
déterminante dans les conséquences des
accidents routiers
il y en a un qui s'appelle la route
elle évolue constamment l art
d'aujourd'hui n'a pas grand chose à voir
à la roue avec la route d'il ya 20 ou 30
ans c'est pas besoin de dire pourquoi ni
comment vous le comprenez très bien
deuxièmement il ya le parc de véhicules
elle est plus gros progrès obtenus
viennent des châssis co qui ont rempli
remplacer les châssis rigide des
ceintures de sécurité des airbags des de
tout de tous les éléments de quillan
améliorer la performance du véhicule
krattinger le dernier paramètre c'est
l'accidentologie qui est due au
comportement des conducteurs qu'est ce
qu'on constate dans les dernières années
il faut le dire alcool drogues
endormissement pourtant et vitesse c'est
pas le plus déterminant quand on regarde
les résultats en 2010 cet automne sur
l'ensemble des excuses accidents de la
vie on regarde avec madame lecaillon ces
quatre paramètres étaient tous impliqués
parce que souvent la vitesse va avec
l'alcool souvent la vitesse va avec la
drogue météo qui a la vitesse
oui mais elles s'additionnent et quand
les gens sont drogués c'est pas le
panneau qui est là qui les empêche de
rouler cédric perrin juste j'aimerais
vous faire réagir à une réaction qu'on a
un que j'ai perdu d'ailleurs françois
qui nous dit il faut savoir reconnaître
quand on a fait une connerie qui
commande
est-ce que vous ayez jusque là c'était
une connerie de vouloir généraliser sur
l'ensemble du réseau
une même vitesse maximale la connerie
c'est de ne plus écouter les gens depuis
maintenant un an et demi connerie c'est
de faire des choses complètement
chaotiques
je pense que c'est une mesure soit
accepté il faut qu'il soit acceptable
or il arrive un moment où ça va c'est
l'histoire de la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase certes on remplit on
remplit ayant sonné ou le goulven le ver
est plat et où ça déborde
et là je pense qu abandonner la goutte
d'eau et a débordé avec les 80
kilomètres y ait d'autres facteurs mais
il faut savoir accepter effectivement
que quand on a fait une erreur de
pouvoir revenir en arrière et de faire
un peu à moi d'honorables pour ça
ça nécessite c'est peut-être eu un
travail sur soi même je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas moi ce que je dis c'est que
ce soit acceptée faut que ce soit
accepté il faut que les gens en prennent
conscience aujourd'hui regardez la
problématique aujourd'hui quel gâchis a
calé un an après quel gâchis même pas
six mois après les radars ont été
détériorées pour 70% d'entre eux on a
changé tous les panneaux etc
moralité on a un manque à gagner quand
même de l'ordre de 500 millions d'euros
donc cette opération si on devait
revenir dessus ce que je souhaite en
tout cas si on devait faire beaucoup
plus de pragmatisme qui on devait donner
aux territoires ruraux ou en tout cas au
territoire tout court une capacité à
décider
et bien ce serait un énorme gâchis
puisqu'on aura dépensé plus de six ou
sept cents millions d'euros parce qu'on
aura refusé d'écouter le sénat qui
demandait à ce qu'on réfléchisse à cette
question et qu'on se donne six mois
d'attentes et aujourd'hui les chiffres
qu'on nous donne il est quand même assez
cocasse de voir que ceux là mêmes qui
nous expliquer qu'il faut au minimum
deux voire 5 ans d'expérience sur une
mesure pour voir si elle a scellé
produit des effets bénéfiques en six
mois c'est la mesure des 80 kilomètres
heure qui viennent diminuer le nombre de
morts sur les routes pour 116 des
chasseuses de seagal dit la sécurité
d'autant plus que c'est la sécurité
c'est pas une science exacte
c'est comme la sécurité c'est pas une
science exacte aujourd'hui quand on vous
cumulez de l'est malheureusement les
décès sur la route c'est aussi sur les
nationales sur les autoroutes en ville
et ses droits mais l'essentiel c'est sur
le réseau secondaire où la majeure
partie des routes est passé à 80 moi je
m'en réjouis que la loi dans son
ensemble
l'ensemble non non non non non 259 à
deux chiffres il ya deux chiffres les
116 morts en moins c'est sur les routes
secondaires majoritairement concernés
par ce avec lui mais il omet de votre
départementale 385 milles vous savez
combien de route qui appartient
aujourd'hui à l'état quand fallait des
autoroutes privé c'est 11500 et moyens
un sujet avec lequel je suis pas
d'accord avec lui mais c'est pas très
très difficile c'est le problème de
l'entretien des routes
parce que si effectivement les routes ne
sont sans doute plus adaptées
aujourd'hui à la circulation routière
qu'elle ne l'était il ya 30 ans en
revanche la baisse des notations qu'on a
subi tous depuis un certain temps où
j'étais maire quand même un certain
temps je peux vous assurer que le
montant des travaux routiers qu'on
faisait il ya 20 ans n'est plus du tout
sans commune mesure
avec ce que l'on fait aujourd'hui ça
veut dire qu'on entretient - les routes
aujourd'hui qu'avant donc accidentologie
ya peut-être aussi de là il ya la
problématique de la cote de la drogue de
l'entretien des routes ces sont des
sujets on devrait déjà parlé avant de
vouloir réfléchir aux 80 km et emmanuel
macron olivier guillemin a dû devant les
maires il ya quelques semaines il faut
ensemble que l'on trouve une manière
plus intelligente de mettre sa
disposition en oeuvre il n'y a pas de
dogme mais comme cédric perrin le disais
tout à l'heure le premier ministre
notamment puisque c'est quand même
edouard philippe qui a pris sur lui et
qu'à assumer cette mesure depuis plus
d'un an maintenant
il a été trop dogmatique le premier
ministre sur cette question j'espère
ainsi il a été trop dogmatique en tout
cas il a il a répondu aussi à la tante
de des associations de sécurité routière
qui voyait effectivement une dégradation
des résultats en matière de sécurité
routière
quand on parle de l'entretien des routes
c'est vrai les conseils départementaux
font des gros efforts et moi je cours de
l'entretien
je peux le constater je suis celui qui à
l'iddri a créé l'observatoire national
de la route je veux joint cédric 1 il ya
des problèmes sur les communes qui ont
eu leur dotation baissé il n'y a pas de
problème c'est le département qui n'ont
pas donné leur niveau
je vais je vais tout à fait dans votre
sens quand on voit la déviation de
sokoto voit le carrefour vers thème qui
était un carrefour très accidenté et je
serais d'accord pour dire que le
département de haute saône et très
proactive sur la question des routes
depuis des années ce sujet du jour mais
c'est pas le sujet du jour j'aimerais
que vous reveniez à la fois son retour
alors par rapport à la vitesse est
justement il ya quand même un élément
important à prendre en compte c'est que
l'accidentologie ne se passe pas sur les
petites routes sinueuses on à 55 % des
accidents mortels qui se déroulent sur
des routes qu'on appelle des belles
routes c'est à dire où il ya des bas
côtés où il ya des îlots directionnels
et c'est ssl ssl conjurer à 90 c'est
nous les gens comme moi y'a juste une
question est juste une question
aujourd'hui on a tous malheureusement
connaissance de gens qui ont de la
famille ou des gens qu'on connaît
directement qui son décès sur la route
malheureusement
et on a régulièrement dans la presse des
gens qui dont on constate qu'ils ont été
et sont de ce week-end sur la route et
sur effectivement parfois des lignes et
des lignes droites le problème c'est ce
que ces gens là se tue à 91 km heure où
est-ce qui sue à 440 est ce que le fait
de limiter la vitesse à 80 va limiter le
nombre de morts et qui va empêcher les
gens se tuent à 140 ou pas c'est ça la
vraie question
les gens qui vont être pénalisés c'est
ce qui roule entre 80 et 85 et qui vont
perdre un point parce qu'ils étaient
cinq kilomètres au dessus de la limite
c'est ça la du dernier mort en haute
saône ces derniers jours villefranque on
la personne s'endort j'ai dit ça après
nous sommes tous préoccupés de sécurité
routière premier ministe pas faire le
procès n'est au maire ni au département
sa première chose deuxièmement
deuxièmement parler du premier ministre
on va l'écouter il s'adresser aux élus
locaux on l'écouté vous répondez juste
après parce que ils vous pointe du doigt
on va on va les voir philippe c'était en
tout début de semaine lors de la
précieuse présentation des chiffres de
la sécurité routière de l'an passé des
chiffres dont il dit qu'ils sont
historiques depuis qu'on mesure
l'accidentologie routière il n'y a
jamais eu aussi peu de morts sur les
routes françaises
les mesures qui ont été mises en place
l'année dernière que 80 km heure
les autres ont joué laurent le rôle dans
cette diminution
nous sommes fiers d'avoir pris nos
responsabilités je pense qu'avant la fin
du débat ou après le débat chacun devra
prendre les siennes en les assumant
devant les français
[Musique]
depuis toujours nous assumons nos
responsabilités devant nos concitoyens
donc vous additionnez la responsable et
ses fameux coupé la parole appels
d'urgence j'aimerais moi je mets ça ne
s'est pas supportable
je m'exprime très clairement nous
assumons complètement la responsabilité
auquel nous y mettons des dizaines et
des dizaines de millions d'euros tous
les ans je voudrais bien que l'état en
fasse autant sur les routes nationales
première chose deuxièmement nous avons
proposé à l'état de travailler ensemble
à une diminution limitation de la
vitesse
la reproposer l'état dit non c'est tout
on n'a pas besoin de vous on décrète que
c'est partout pareil
ce n'est pas logique ça ne correspond à
aucune doctrine routière établi né en
france ni ailleurs et donc nous
proposons non pas une baisse uniforme et
une baisse qu'ils soient adaptés à
l'état à la circulation au centre ville
la rue il y a des éléments clés que nous
connaissons qui relève d'ailleurs de
catalogue de l'état maintenant quand
j'ai fait ça moi et que les services du
département
on arrive à 90 7 111 km sur 3450 vous
allez claes et peaufiné ute monlézun
claveria entendre la catégorie 90
km/heure 711 à 80 km/heure 1426 et ac 70
km/heure dans les zones où aujourd'hui
personne n'en parle mais y arrive quand
même qu'il y ait des accidents 1500
kilomètres donc les départements étaient
tous d'accord pour travailler là dessus
et je dis la question qui était posée au
départ par monsieur bah elle est bien
posée soit dans ce pays m'ont trahi tous
ensemble
au regard des résultats soit il ya des
oukases d'eau et bien depuis le début je
m'excuse de le dire et c'est un grand
regret pour moi il y a beaucoup
d'occases dans beaucoup de domaines je
constate que ça ne va pas avec les
français le perçoivent et ne partage pas
et quand je dis ça en haute saône tout
le monde me dit y compris monsieur mon
ami michel raison puisque on se connaît
depuis le lycée dix dernières années que
ça sans rapport tous les noms mali même
bord politique oui une nouvelle
est ce que vraiment la sécurité routière
que ce traité sur le plan politiciens
les deux sens
le récit c'est tout ne vous fait pas
tout mal il me faisait pas mal mais je
m'exprime
il ya des offres sur les radars et on
dit la mesure est acceptée alors que ce
que je propose dans des réunions
régulièrement les indices tu as raison
tu as raison et donc est ce qu on fait
confiance à la france en recommandant
n'explique en travaillant sur le fond ou
pas cédric perrin réservé en d'art tout
à l'heure en disant que les gens se
faisait attraper à 82 kilomètres heure
mais si on repasse un tronc soit 70 un
tronçon à 81 tronçons à 90 route
on va vous les automobiles vont dire la
même chose on s'y perd ça change tout le
temps ça suppose mans ça suppose de le
faire où les blancs ça suppose il ya des
progrès à faire sur les routes
nationales compliqué ça suppose de le
faire intelligemment
il faut que effectivement il y est avec
moi je pose je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que ça doit pas être le seul
département les seuls conseils
départementaux qui doivent gérer ça il
ya sécurité routière la prévention
routière ya les préfectures il ya des
gens qui connaissent donc ça doit être
un travail collectif avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
mais je voudrais revenir sur un point
qui moi me paraît fondamental et 80 km
heure j étais opposé dès le départ mais
j'en fais pas une question de dogmatisme
jeu ce que je voudrais essayer de faire
comprendre c'est que abandonné la vraie
question qu'on se pose quand on à moi je
suis pas je pense ici entre deux eaux
jeu pas très vieux jeu pas très jeune
mais la vraie question que nous pose
c'est quelle société on construit c'est
quelle société on construit demain est
ce que c'est une société qui est fait
d'interdît où on va t'il décidé de tout
pour les gens on va leur dire on n'est
pas le droit de conduire à plus de 80
kilomètres heure là il peut vous avez
droit de fumer mais tant de cigarettes
vous avez doivent nous faire payer l'air
qu'on respire etc
c'est la société qu'on construit pour
nos enfants de demain et moi je suis pas
pour une société d'interdits je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi
laisser un peu de souffle aux gens et on
a vu très bien et il rate un gel a dit
que si cette mesure était était si
accepter que ce que ça peut être
n'aurions nous pas aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des radars du pays qui sont
dégradées je vous donne la parole mais
juste est ce que vous croyez que le port
de la ceinture de sécurité était bien
accepté au début l'amélioration des
véhicules non je ne me pose pas près 50
en ville c'était bien accepté il ya
trouvé 6 11 mais jérémy si on veut si on
veut qu'ils aient plus de morts sur la
route on supprime les kalou à le faire
rouler les gens à 10 km si on veut
piquer mort de mort du cancer du poumon
et on ne supprime la cigarette circuit
quai de pneumo revue alcool on supprime
l'alcool c'est quelle société on veut
second veut construire demain guimond
je rejoue m super sur ce sujet là c'est
un sujet qui est actuellement très
présent dans les débats qu'on peut la
compagnie mais moi j'ai encore animer un
débat mercredi soir dans le cadre du
grand débat national sur la thématique
de la démocratie et de la citoyenneté
parce qu'effectivement quel est le rôle
de l'élu et quelle est la problématique
de la représentativité de l'élu est ce
qu'il est effectivement censé
représenter l'ensemble des intérêts
particuliers ou est ce qu'à un moment il
doit aussi endosser le rôle de
responsable et de et de prod et
l'intérêt général c'est quand même
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
aujourd'hui dans le débat actuel qu'un
moment finalement on trouve cet
équilibre entre représentativité et
intérêt général
parce que je suis d'accord on peut
considérer ça comme une multiplication
de perte de liberté maintenant je pense
pas que edouard philippe quand il a
proposé ça il était dans une logique de
supprimer les libertés
il était dans une logique d'intérêt
général et vous avez parié que la
question c'est déjà ça la question c'est
la question de la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase
et à force d'interdire n'interdire
d'interdire d'obliger et d'obliger est
obligé de fiscaliser de fiscaliser et
bien les gens en ont ras le bol parce
que je pense que ça adapté de
gouvernements de gauche de droite et au
bout d'un moment mme allard en blague il
se remplit et la balle a été trop
remplie et donc je pense qu'il faut
faire un mouvement de recul et peut-être
réfléchir avant une politique à long
terme est de se dire quelle société on
veut vraiment construire et moi je le
dis très honnêtement aujourd'hui servi
dans une société où tout le monde dès
lors qu'ils prendraient tient des propos
qui ne plaisent pas et mieux se voit
offrir un procès en sorcellerie ou la
parole de plus libre on est dans un pays
où les journalistes se font matraquer ou
où les gens dès lors qu'il dise quelque
chose qui ne va pas dans le sens de 2,2
delà de la con dirais-je de de la
conscience ou de la pensée majoritaire
et bien quelqu'un qui doit être c'est ça
la vraie que s'éloigne j'ai l'âme et
vous parliez tout à l'heure de du rôle
des associations prévention routière
notamment où l'avait cité
je vous propose d'écouter yves lemaire
il est le patron
régional bourgogne franche comté de la
prévention routière on lui a demandé si
revenir sur cette mesure du 80 km/heure
généralisée était une bonne chance
d'écouter sa réponse sera une erreur et
je pense que déjà six minutes soit le
nombre de morts si minime soit il si
important soit-il
je n'ai jamais au rendez vous nos hommes
politiques qu'on pense et une vie sur la
route
le drame que ça engendre pour les autres
notre slogan c'est soyons responsables
sur la route
faisons tout pour rue sauvé des vies sur
la route et faire tout pour sauver des
vies sur la route baisser la vitesse
c'est une très bonne mesure
[Musique]
soyons responsables
il sera temps j'essaie peu ou prou le
même discours qu edouard philippe
en quoi les élus locaux sont les mieux à
même de juger de la vitesse maximale
autorisée que les experts de la sécurité
routière de leur exemple parce qu'avec
leurs techniciens se crasse et qui
dessine les profils des routes etc une
route ça a une capacité limitée qu'une
route ça doit être ça ne pardonne et les
petites choses
les petites fautes mais pas forcément
les grandes mais j'ai dit puisque on en
arrive à leurs responsabilités moi je
demande à l'état de régler trois
problèmes
l'endormissement il y a aujourd'hui des
pare-brises comme d'hier on a mis de ses
cris ceinture de sécurité qui permettent
que quand vous fermez les yeux quand
vous tournez la tête la voiture ralentit
et s'arrête ça existe
donc on le fait sans les bras tout cela
à personne qui est victime à terry j
elle sera encore la deuxième chose
l'alcoomètre on est prêt à le mettre
dans les camions alors il faut être
courageux
y'a pas que les camions qui roulent sur
les routes il faut traiter ça ça c'est
une mesure de fonds ensuite est-ce qu'on
peut continuer à couvrir le réseau
d'émetteurs de téléphonie mobile toutes
catégories confondues qui encourage les
gens et on envoie des centaines et des
centaines tous les jours qu'ils
téléphonent au volant qui n'ont pas
encore aujourd'hui virer leur cuti
si demain l'état décide que tout
conducteur pris au volant
on n'a plus de permis on en verra
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins il faut
que l'état soit courageux lui parce que
dans les départements que ce soit réparé
dans les autres dans le bien chaque
accident est analysée même quand on
n'est pas concerné a priori je trouve
que c'est presque par rapport à nous
enfin je parle peu démodé à g et très
agressif de considérer que les élus se
foutent de ça ce n'est pas vrai
même un sujet majeur de nos travaux on
est tous des élus responsables
la question de la sécurité routière on a
tous parfaitement conscience et la
volonté du premier depuis le départ 5 t
de culpabiliser les éduque les autres
façons mais moi je suis pour la sécurité
ou bien vous vous n'êtes pas c'est pas
ça la question
la question c'est qu'on est tous
extrêmement conscient qu'il faut faire
des progrès mais la problématique c'est
que c'est ce que j'ai tout à la sécurité
routière ce n'est pas une science exacte
aujourd'hui les progrès de la médecine
la progrès de la rapidité avec laquelle
les secours interviennent sur les
accidents laa l'extrême progrès progrès
qu'ont fait les véhicules aujourd'hui
moi je suis venu avec ma voiture pour
venir un peu attention je suis désolé
aujourd'hui nous voitures et les poteaux
nommé l'un n'est pas loin on a des
progrès extraordinaires tout ça ça
participe évidemment la diminution du
nombre de morts sur la route à la
diminution du nombre d'accidents
aujourd'hui vouloir faire croire que la
seule mesure des 80 km/heure et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le nombre de morts
sur la route a diminué et man est un
mensonge
il y a beaucoup d'éléments qui entrent
en ligne de compte
et le fait de le sénat avait de la météo
c'est une juste raison et vous le faites
comme le sénat l'avait demandé de
peut-être faire travailler que les élus
locaux et faire en sorte qu'on ait
d'évadés des variantes de route en
fonction de la capacité qu'on aille
rouler ou pas c'est important
aujourd'hui il ya des routes sur
lesquelles on peut pas rouler à 80 et
pourtant il se remit à 4080 il n'a
d'autre je suis désolé sur lesquels on
roule à 80 et elle c'est très compliqué
d'arriver à se maintenir 80 ou 90 il ya
la problématique aussi aujourd'hui de
l'étagement de l'étalement des rapports
de vitesse sur des voitures automatiques
si vous les avez une voiture automatique
vous essayez de vous la 80ème vous
roulez en cinquième ou quatrième si vous
avez 5 vitesses donc qu'est-ce qu'elle
quid de quid de la consommation de
carburant quid de l'environnement on n'a
pas réfléchi à tout ça on au milieu on a
fait les choses de manière dogmatique et
comment vertical sans se réfléchir à ce
que ça allait donner aujourd'hui le
résultat
legault une réaction de syrie je dois
vous préciser que quand on a commencé à
faire des débats ce pas le premier débat
sur les 80 km alors que l'on fait on
avait d avalanche de réactions contre
les 80 km et l'appareil honte pour cette
émission c'est un peu en train de
changer on a des gens qui s'affiche pour
une majorité de réaction contre mais on
a déjà regardé par l'ong cyril qui nous
dit personne n'est pour cette limitation
sauf les familles de victimes de la
route les droits de quoi il a le droit
je dis non il n'ya pas que les familles
de victimes olivier guillemain
rapidement le gouvernement il est
courageux ou pas sur cette question
parce que c'est
c'est ce que pointe et il fera à tanger
le gouvernement était courageux de
proposer cette cette mesure maintenant
il est l écoute et je pense
qu'effectivement ce qui a été dit par le
président de la république est plus ou
moins
sous-entendu par le premier ministre
d'adapter effectivement cette question
là c'est en lien avec les collectivités
c'est fini merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition spéciale grand débat bon
dimanche à tous
[Musique]